there's a lot to unpack in the latest
Godzilla flicks ending from what the
human characters might do next to what
this rapidly expanding fictional
universe could imply about the future of
the ancient beings known as Titans let's
break it all down and explain the ending
of Godzilla king of the monsters monster
spoilers ahead Godzilla king of the
monsters ends exactly the way you'd
expect it to with a massive Titan vs.
Titan showdown in the ruins of Boston as
Godzilla and Ghidorah battle it out for
apex predator status the film ultimately
reveals that Godzilla who seems to be
working side by side with humanity has
prevailed by showing us the king of the
monsters chowing down on one of Ghidorah
's heads before blasting the remains of
the alien monster with his atomic breath
and then this exchange happens for now
it's an ominous PostScript added by
monarchs resident mythologist who seems
to understand that even though some
version of a balance has been achieved
with Godzilla's victory it could all go
very wrong at any moment the line for
now might just seem like a teaser for
more sequels but Dr Chen's warning
speaks to the fragility of life on earth
in the wake of the film everything old
is new again and that means new rules
for everyone that could be breaking at
any moment midway through the film
Godzilla managed to chew off one of
Ghidorah heads before the oxygen
destroyer weapon was deployed and
rendered Godzilla dormant Ghidorah was
unaffected by the destroyer because as
it turns out he's an alien species who
invaded the earth millennia ago a barren
land laid to waste by the vile brute
known as
[Music]
being an alien means he's also capable
of regrowing his head but what about the
original noggin we have to wait until a
post-credits scene to find out what
happened but it turns out that extra
severed Ghidorah head was picked up by
fishermen and offered to Allen Jonah and
his eco-terrorist group
Jonah's original plan was to awaken the
Titans one at a time to restore balance
to the world
and that plan fell apart when Ghidorah
woke up all the Titans himself so what
can Jonah do with a Ghidorah head that
he couldn't do before well he could just
be selling off the creatures DNA as a
valuable resource or he could have
grander designs a resurrected Ghidorah
under the control of a human master
could change the game for all Titans and
Jonah himself could be the king of the
monsters that's if he can manage to
bring monster zero back at all and
that's a big if this plan is what you
were calling a long shot well that's
good stop it it's been a common feature
of Godzilla films for decades now that
Mothra emerges as a benevolent
self-sacrificing figure who wants to
live in harmony with humans rather than
battle them and the queen of the
monsters lived up to that legacy in this
film after defeating Rodin a weakened
Mothra sacrificed herself in battle
against Ghidorah to help Godzilla with
her essence falling on the king of the
monsters to give him a little added
boost when he needed it
luckily that's not the end of Mothra
news clippings in the film's closing
credits suggest the queen is simply
regenerating and will eventually emerge
from another cocoon the film also
suggests that when she does return
Mothra won't be alone the Chen twins
seemed to be more than just two
scientists with an intense interest in
monsters their devotion to titans plus
their statuses twins points to them
being the monster vers version of the
show b gene the twin theories in the
original films who worship Mothra on its
home of infant Island we very likely
haven't seen the last of them throughout
the film we see references to Kong the
king of Skull Island who was the star of
the second film in the monster verse and
who will return again next year to
battle godzilla what we never actually
see in the film is anything new from
Kong himself even as titans around the
world are waking up and responding to
Ghidorah so why didn't Congress pond
well the simple answer could just be
that he's on an island and isn't
equipped to cross through the storms
that surrounded and make his way across
the ocean but there may be more to it
news clippings at the end of the film
note that Titans are making their way
towards Skull Island
seemingly setting the stage for Godzilla
vs Kong
if Kong is powerful enough to have
resisted gu Dory's orders that places
him in rare company alongside Mothra and
Godzilla as one of the strongest
monsters on the planet his absence is
not a sign of weakness but a sign of
strength and of course a sequel early in
the film dr. Stanton theorizes that
godzilla is able to move so quickly
under water because the earth is in fact
hollow and the titan is using tunnels
under oceans that have yet to be
discovered by man this theory is laughed
off until the monarch team follows a
dormant Godzilla into the depths later
in the film and discovers that there's
more than just tunnels there's also an
entire underwater city down there news
clippings in the film's closing credits
reveal that this information has been
made public and now the whole world
knows that Hollow Earth humans once
worshipped and coexisted with the Titans
of course the underwater city we see in
the film was presumably destroyed by the
nuclear explosion that was set off to
repower Godzilla but if there really was
a culture of people worshipping the
first gods it's hard to imagine that
city was the only one even as the cities
of the world are destroyed by the Titans
gods
king of the monsters also does its best
to keep a human heart at its center much
of that heart centers on the Russell
family which was torn apart by
Godzilla's battle in San Francisco in
2014 as the film goes on Maddie has to
watch her mother who was once her hero
become what she calls a monster before
earning Redemption by sacrificing
herself in the fight to defeat Ghidorah
when the dust settles mark and Madison
are the only two members of the family
left the film leaves their future
open-ended but we already know Milly
Bobby Brown will return for Godzilla vs.
Kong so the Russell's are clearly
planning to stick close to the Titans
for at least a little while longer king
of the monsters spends most of its run
time focusing on the title monster
Godzilla and three other key players
among the Titans Ghidorah Mothra and
Rodan despite what trailers might
suggest though these creatures are far
from the only Titans in the film though
we only glimpse a few of them they often
seem to be creatures we've never seen
before in Godzilla films most
prominently the giant spider Scylla and
the mammoth creature behemoth but
monarch is never done searching and the
revelation of alien titans as well as
underwater cities leaves them with more
places to look the world of titans is
vast at the end of the film that there's
always room to grow and we can probably
expect more Titans to emerge along with
more sequels check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you